politique très connue quand j'avais 25
ans quand j'avais ton âge ruiz qui
m'avait un peu draguer voilà ça c'est
pour les indices mais je dirai pas son
nom un peu lourdement ragués mais qui
était un mec assez charismatique et
c'est donc j'avais 25 ans j'étais un peu
m'avait dit à 40 ans les femmes de 40
ans sont le sont à l'acmé de leur vie
sont à l'acmé de leur beauté l'acmé de
leur puissance et n'avait pas du tout
compris j'avais l'impression qu'ils me
disaient ça veut dire quoi à 25 ans
shimon et je serai est en fait il avait
raison c'est la seule chose que je vis
que je lui laisse de juste parce que non
il n'y avait aucun harcèlement mais une
forme de drague appuyé voilà c'est pas
vous un jour la femme non c'est pas moi
ça va je
pense à tout ce qu'elle a pu souffrir
attention évidemment le combat est
important
que toutes les filles on est arrivé lui
maghrib a dragué non là ça devient donc
c'est un peu faux pas les trous là non
plus
ça devient ridicule de maintenance et un
jour une histoire journal quelque chose
et c il m'a peu dingue et c'était un peu
lourd en face à cc elle c'est aberrant
mais je porte ma part des machins là ça
devient vraiment vraiment vraiment
ridicule ridicule oui les questionnons
ce qui gêne on sait que ces quotidiens
il ya une affaire de tous les jours et
quand on écoute toutes ces accusations
on a l'impression que tous les hommes en
politique et dans les médias sont de
dangereux prédateurs sexuels donc c'est
insupportable et ce qui est d'autant
plus grave c'est de mettre sur un pied
d'égalité les viols qui sont extrêmement
graves dépressions de dragun plus loin
franchement c'est n'importe quoi enfin
sur le genou est encore avec pénétration
autour
du maire guy sié rien mais redit gc a
égalisé à baba petite soeur si tu
laisses un homme à mettre la main sur le
genou on avait là de suite parce que
sinon tout le reste y passe
[Rires]
je devais que les gens mais maintenant
mais pas les méchants j'ai un respect
énorme pour les grands champions
je suis d'accord avec mes camarades
évidemment on peut pas tout mettre sur
le même plan on peut pas mettre
quelqu'un qui vous dit que vous êtes
séduisante vous êtes jolie sur le même
plan qu'un harceleur voir un violeur en
revanche bien il ya une petite flamme
qui a qui est en train d'arriver une
petite vaguelette qui va peut-être
devenir une lame de fond qui racheta qui
est le mythe ou politique et on va on va
on va certainement voir des affaires
dans le monde politique et c'est pas
grave et tant mieux je vois pas pourquoi
vous vous offusquez pourquoi est ce que
le monde politique seraient exempts et
on aurait construit c'est quand même à
faire et qui n'ose rêver je viens de
dire en préambule quelque chose est ce
que tu as écouté le cuir on laisse
entendre que dès qu'une femme parle elle
a forcément raison pardon encore une
enquête raconte intensément j'ai dit
depuis hier et c'est pas la première
fois que je le dis c'est que l'huile
qu'une fois une femme parle il faut
l'écouter fola pour la croix et oui mais
après tu peux te lances que tu veux mais
il faut la croire